benefits let's go here i've told you
guys this at the very beginning of our
speedrun the knight and the queen
is the strongest pair of attackers on
the chessboard there is no
pair of two pieces not even a queen and
a rook in some regards
that are as strong of attackers as the
queen and the knight
because of their ability to control
squares because of their ability to
defend each other
because of their ability to deliver
checkmate hello
yes my name is daniel mereditsky no
i'm not busy at all you would like me to
file your taxes in my mind
right now you say okay i can do that for
you
let me do that while i calculate 30
moves in this hyperbola game
no it's really no problem i have trained
my brain to section off tasks to
separate parts
go ahead and read off your 1099 income
statements
i will automatically generate your
returns within approximately
32.6 seconds amazing how that came
together
no not this game he's already lost
i finally finished the bob ross painting
from seven years ago
in my mind per pixel he was right though
it needed trees bad luck right there
oh man that is just really that happens
to everybody
oh man now he takes me me
me
oh my this is the most epic moment i've
ever had and it didn't even happen to me
i think i just i think i just pissed
myself
move no
oh my god
unbelievable i cannot believe i won that
but i'll take it
could get him but if he pushes pawn up
is that position where my queen is
like where my queen is there is that a
better position or is that still just
not even worse
so you can play this yeah this is a good
move now knight f6 is probably the best
but queen f6 is a very decent move
because he might take your knight that's
actually possible miss maiden one
imagine what what what that would create
the problem is again
if he knows what to do he plays bishop
to e3 here
then queen f6 is a slightly inaccurate
movie basically trans
transpose into theory but i would you
know why don't you risk it
i would just risk it i like that yeah
we are up a pawn
please tell me i'm dreaming please tell
me i'm dreaming
this is exactly what we practiced for
exactly what we practiced our mind
is throbbing throbbing
down there it is a [ __ ] prophet
he he said he played the scotch game and
he did
right um man good times good times
of course it unbelievable
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
you